hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about
metformin so i'll begin by talking about
metformin in general what it is and why
you have
possibly already heard of it because
it's currently being used to treat type
2 diabetes
and then we'll look at the application
of metformin
in this recent cell metabolism paper and
how
this study reinforces other studies that
have shown that metformin may have
anti-inflammatory effects and then
briefly
basically i got a little bit carried
away whilst making this video
and was reading all the different
literature about
the potential use of metformin for
alleviating symptoms of cavit19 as i
came across a really good
summary review article that well
effectively summarizes a lot of the
observational data that's been collected
over the last few months so i'll talk
about that at the end of the video
but let's get going let's start with
what is metformin
so i thought i hadn't mentioned
metaforming before in this channel but i
have
a couple of times actually but i didn't
really go into any detail about it
so what you're looking at now is
metformin or to give
the correct name nn dimethyl emido
dicarbonomidic diamide i didn't even
know if i said that right
but what's gonna think of metformin for
now so metformin
is the first line medication for the
treatment of type 2 diabetes
so it's used to treat high blood sugar
levels
and so type 2 diabetes is an
age-associated disease
and according to this article there's a
projection that by 2050
one in three u.s adults could have type
2 diabetes
however the molecular mechanism of
metformin isn't completely understood
and a variety of potential mechanisms
have been given
some of these include inhibition of
oxidative phosphorylation within the
mitochondria
activation of ampk which as you can see
in this diagram here
is thought to also help to activate
sertoins
and to suppress the grave signaling
pathways within a cell
and also impinges on insulin signaling
which explains its efficacy
as a type 2 diabetes treatment
and even more recent studies now seem to
show that metformin can have significant
effects on the gut microbiome as well
altering the composition
and those alterations are also mediating
the beneficial outcome
of the use of metformin and type 2
diabetes management
however metformin's become even more of
interest recently because
studies have shown that metformin can
extend lifespan
in mice and also as explained in this
research article older men who had been
taking metformin
because they had type 2 diabetes also
had a reduced likelihood
of getting dementia cancer depression
and cardiovascular disease just by
taking
metformin and so these diseases are also
age-associated diseases
and so what has been initiated is the
targeting aging with metformin trial
which is a nationwide
six-year clinical trials at 14 different
research institutions that are trying to
assess the efficacy
of metformin in preventing these
different age-associated diseases
and so one of the hallmarks of aging
that is associated with these different
diseases
is inflammation or sometimes referred to
as
inflammation and this generally refers
to
the cytokines that are secreted within
the body
such as tnf alpha and interleukin 6
that also seem to increase in abundance
during aging however what is currently
less understood
is what is the cause of this
inflammation in the first place
where are these cytokines coming from
and so
one source of this inflammation can come
from senescent cells
but another major source comes from t
cells
which are a subset of immune cells
within the body
and so given that there is accumulating
evidence that
metformin may have anti-inflammatory
effects as well
the cell metabolism paper sought to
explore
the impact of metformin on
age-associated
t-cell inflammation and so the work in
this paper helps to uncover further the
potential mechanisms
underpinning the behavior and effects of
metformin within the body
so the authors began by examining the
cytokine secreted by
activated t cells taken from healthy
30 year old and 60 year old people to
see how
age influences the cytokine profile
and so if we look at this figure here we
can see that in the older
t-cells there were higher secretion
levels of
interleukin 17a 17f
21 and 6 and these are associated
with the subset of t cells the t helper
cells 17
subset whose presence is used as a
predictor for type 2 diabetes
and also promotes gum disease however
when
the older t cells were given metformin
the same time that they were activated
the levels of these different cytokines
reduced to
the same level as seen in the young
t-cells
so what has happened in the older
t-cells
to enable them to secrete more of these
th17
cytokines so there were two key lines of
evidence that helped to elucidate this
question the first was that when they
knocked down
autophagy in the young t-cells
they actually activated this th17
profile
into the young cells and so autophagy is
a natural process within cells that
removes
unnecessary and dysfunctional components
that includes
damaged proteins and organelles within
the cell
and the second line of evidence came
from the observation that
the older t cells had increased levels
of reactive oxygen species
and these levels were reduced when
metformin was given to the cells
however to really understand what
metformin is doing
a molecular underpinning to these
changes is required
and so whilst this paper still doesn't
really find
uh exactly what metaformin is doing
upstream it
identifies stat three which is a
transcription factor
that actually upregulates this th17
secretion of cytokines as a downstream
signaling component
of this inflammatory activation and the
authors show that
aging seems to promote stats
reactivation whilst metformin has the
impact of preventing this activation
and thus also reducing the expression of
these different cytokines
so what can we take from this paper well
i found a really good summary
at the end of this science mag
commentary
which is basically is there enough
evidence to take metformin to rejuvenate
our immune system and promote healthy
aging
well not quite yet mainly because this
paper didn't do
any assessments on chronic low-grade
inflammation in fivo
and also didn't examine the contribution
of other immune cells such as monocytes
and macrophages
in driving inflammating however what the
authors claim in this paper
is at least that work should justify the
start of full-scale clinical trials
using this
t helper cell 17 inflammation as a
primary outcome
but the other reason why research like
this is interesting
is because inflammation is associated
with one of the outcomes of covered 19
infected patients which is the
respiratory failure referred to as
acute respiratory distress syndrome and
the other link to cover 19 is the fact
that
patients with type 2 diabetes are
associated with both
poorer clinical outcomes during the
pandemic and an increased
risk of death in hospitalized patients
so as i mentioned earlier as i was
preparing for this video i came across
this really concise review article
and effectively what they do in this
review article is they
took data from different observational
retrospective studies
and looked at the reduction of mortality
in metformin users compared with
non-users
and we'll just explore some of the data
that they collected
so firstly this article suggested
mechanisms to explain the possible
positive effects of metformin on covid19
outcomes
and so these include things that we
spoke about earlier such as improving
glucose control
and also activating ampk but this time
they're a bit more obviously specific
and relating to k-19 so in particular
they in one study they showed that ampk
activation
leads to phosphorylation of ace2 which
can actually inhibit
the virus penetration into the cells and
so i spoke about
ace two in like well in a fully i
suppose i made months ago now
initially talking about um sars cough
two
but it also suggests that by reducing
body weight
and also inhibiting the mtor pathway
as other possible positive effects of
taking metformin
but what about the actual data that
they've seen so as i mentioned they took
data from different
studies that have been conducted during
the pandemic so far
and effectively what you can see is that
there seems to be
a reduction in mortality in metformin
users compared with non-users
among patients with type 2 diabetes
hospitalized for cavity 19
however as this article also cautions a
firm conclusion about the impact of
metformin therapy can only be drawn from
double-blind
randomized controlled trials and
currently
it's very challenging to use such trials
and also the fact that
metformin is out of patent and very
inexpensive and so
getting funding to do such studies is
also
a challenge although i didn't i didn't
entirely know too much about how
these trials are conducted so since i
was talking about metformin in this
video i thought it was worth mentioning
this
as well so as always i hope you have
learned something
from the variety of different studies
that i've spoken about in this video
and as always thanks for listening